let's go to our caller from the 2:03
area code who is calling today from 2:03
hello David
yes oh hey my name is Josh I'm from
Connecticut hey Josh um and I just I
just watched Trump's speeches morning
the response to uh you know the attack
on the Iraqi base right and you seem
really tired you know you just woke up
but yeah uh and you know basically it
was short he said like you know doesn't
seem like we're doing any sort of
military strike like as of now we don't
really know yeah I got from that speech
was he actually seems okay take it like
as I said on the program the day of the
of the strikes Iran kind of handed Trump
a way out if he wants it which is they
got a retaliation on the record for
Kasim soleimani
it didn't lead to any casualties and now
if Trump wants to gracefully exit
without doing more he can do it maybe
without feeling like he's a beta male as
the those on the right might say and if
he's determined deescalate he also can
and it seems as though he doesn't seem
that interested in escalating as of
right now yeah but that wasn't really my
question like my main question is like
Canada's huge speculation territory like
like we don't really know what the
future holds but like let's just
speculate worst-case scenario if like
there is like some sort of all-out war
with Iran do you think there would end
up being like so many sort of use of
Selective Service like a cave a draft
because like like personally I don't
really think so either yeah I did a lot
earlier this week and a lot of people
were talking about the draft could I get
drafted what's going I don't think the
the the volunteer military in the United
States both thankfully and concerning
Lee like why so many people want to be
in the military is an area of concern
although some are doing it for economic
reasons and okay we can talk about that
but also fortunately the volunteer
military is so big that the size of the
armed conflict that would necessitate a
draft would be so huge that I don't
think that that's a likely outcome at
all
of even if there's a major escalation
with Iran I don't see a draft yeah maybe
we haven't used it in like what six
years or something like that yeah like
it was done in Vietnam that wasn't 60
years ago but oh I don't got my numbers
wrong all right um like I'm really
mainly asking this to like I'm 18 year
old college student go to Yukons go
Huskies so a lot of people I know are
kind of concerned about this whole thing
I totally get it I I do not based on
everything we know right now I don't
think you have to worry
I really don't yeah like I understood
like the concern from some people but I
honestly don't think like it would end
up being issue I just want to know your
opinion on the whole thing all right
very good well that's a bye I hope that
I am NOT wrong because if I'm wrong on
this a lot of people have some very ugly
things coming up so so I hope that I'm
right on this oh yeah all right thanks
very much a phone call I apologize to
everybody I was not able to get to but I
am out of time we will take calls again
we'll take a quick break and be back
with more right after this